[APPLAUSE]
ERIC SCHMIDT: You
know, it's interesting,
in learning about the
history of America,
we take for granted
that we don't have
child labor in this country.
But it's a relatively
recent idea.
The protections that when
we take for granted now
in the United States
started 100 years ago,
but they were ruled
unconstitutional,
very interesting.
And it wasn't until
the Depression
that it seems no
brainer restrictions
that we have on the misuse
of children in the workforce
became law.
And even in the United
States, we today
have exemptions for things
like agricultural work.
I was shocked to discover
that this problem exists
in the United States.
What's interesting about
our Nobel Prize winner is,
in addition to being a
truly great human being,
he's one of the two Nobel
Prize winners in the Peace
Prize from India, and he's often
compared to the other, Mother
Teresa.
That's what it takes, I think,
to serve the world in the way
that you have.
And I thought it would be very
interesting to talk about what
the problem is, how we address
it, what Google can do to help,
and all of that.
There is one thing that
Google could do to help,
which I don't think
you know, which
is that as of this
very moment, we
are announcing $150,000
donation to your charity to help
this in India and elsewhere.
So congratulations.
So that's a donation
from google.org
to sort of help along.
The organization that
we know and we've
worked with that you've
built is fantastic.
So maybe we could start
by, you're probably
the leader in fighting
against child exploitation,
child slavery, all
that sort of stuff,
I think for your
whole adult life.
Maybe you can
define the problem,
how big it is, where are
the pitfalls, those sorts
of things.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Thank you.
And once again, I will thank
you for this new announcement.
That's a surprise.
Thanks.
We live in a world of
high speed internet
and globalization of technology
and science, information,
knowledge, products, markets.
And partly you should be
credited for that, the Google
and Google's people, in building
up a global knowledge village.
But on the other hand, we
still have 168 million children
in full time jobs.
85 million of them
are living and working
in most appalling
conditions, what
we call the worst forms of
child labor under the UN law.
5 and 1/2 million children
are slaves, virtually,
those who cannot move, those
who cannot change their jobs,
and forced to work.
And most of the cases
they're confined
to work places, in
mines, in quarries,
at [INAUDIBLE], factories,
workshops, houses, restaurants,
and so on.
Children are sold and
bought like animals.
If you allow, I will
tell you a short story.
Some years ago,
we were organizing
a march against
child trafficking
for forced labor or slavery,
the South Asian march,
involving India, Pakistan,
and Nepali children.
And after the day long
awareness activities,
we were just relaxing
after dinner,
and I saw that a
group of children
were sitting and talking among
each other-- Indian, Pakistani,
Nepali, Bangladeshi.
And one of them
asked to other, that
do you have any idea how much
money you have been sold for?
A girl said, I can't recall,
but maybe 5,000 rupees.
That is something
about $80 or so.
Then two other children
replied, oh, we
are even lucky that we have been
sold for 7,000 rupees, little
more, more than $100.
And then another girl
stood up and said, oh, I
am even better
because I have been
sold many years ago
for 10,000 rupees.
And then one of
the boys stood up
and asked four of them
that, can you recall,
do you have any
idea that how much
is the prize of a buffalo
in your country, or a cow?
The buffalo was quite
common in South Asia.
And they looked at each
other, and then one of them
replied, maybe 50,000 rupees.
Another said, no, no.
In my country, it's
about 100,000 rupees.
I was listening,
and I was in tears.
What are we talking about?
These children are comparing
with buffalo and cows.
A buffalo is sold for
100,000 rupees and a girl
for 10,000 rupees, 10
times the buffalo's cost.
We are not talking
about medieval slavery.
We are talking about
the modern day slavery.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I
think maybe everyone
is having the same reaction.
How is this possible today?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
It is the reality.
And I would say that
the saddest commentary
on modern times in one sentence
is that child slavery still
exists.
And this is possible because
we don't have enough political
will to control the systems.
It is also because
of the social mindset
which does not
recognize and respect
the dignity of
childhood and dignity
of children, so social customs
and so on, cultural problems.
Also, we have not been
able invested adequate
for our children.
Look, only $18 billion
additional funding
is needed annually to bring all
children to school and educate.
And that is less than a
week's military expenditure
of the world.
We are not so poor.
But even then, we are
not able to invest
enough on our children, on their
health, on their protection.
We don't have
protective systems.
That is also problem.
So this combination of these
things keep on working.
ERIC SCHMIDT: But there's
a whole convention.
There's a set of laws.
There's something called
the Internationally Labor
Organization, and rules.
America, for example, with
exception of agriculture
has rules where you can't
be employed below 12.
At 14, you can, but with
certain restrictions.
At 16, you can, but with some
restrictions around danger.
And at 18, you're
considered an adult.
And I think that conforms
roughly with the rules.
Is the problem that
they signed the law,
and then they
don't implement it?
Or did they just
not sign the law?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Most
of them sign the laws.
170 countries globally have
ratified the Convention
on Worst Forms of Child Labor.
That means no child
shall be allowed
to work in hazardous
occupations in worst forms
up to the age of 18.
But despite that, it goes on.
As I said, 85 million
children are the victims
of worst forms of child labor.
So one thing is moral
and legal accountability.
Another thing is the serious
amount of political will
which is lacking.
And thirdly, strong
civil society,
because the politicians
act when there
is a demand from their voters
or from the communities
and societies.
And these children whom
we are talking about
are neither the
voters, or nor they
can influence the
politics of any country.
So that's why it is very, very
important than the voices,
strong voices should come
in favor of children,
because children are not
able to speak for themselves.
They are almost invisible,
most ignored and neglected.
Civil society is not so
cohesive and strong that
can speak with
one voice and hold
the government accountable.
Also, the business
is accountable,
because businesses also
have very strong role
to play, especially when it
comes to the supply chain.
Most of the products are
now which we are using,
from [INAUDIBLE] to shoes,
and many more things,
are produced by children in
different parts of the world,
by the suppliers and the
local subcontractors,
petty contractors.
So more transparency,
more accountability
in the entire supply chain
and the global business
is equally needed.
So the combination of
those things are missing.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You know, you
created this Save the Children
movement, and you're credited
with saving somewhere
between 60,000 and
100,000 children
from this sort of thing in
India and with many hundreds
of villages that you worked.
What did you actually
do to make this happen?
Was it speaking?
Was it visiting?
How did you do it?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
Well, every day
when I come to my office
in South Delhi, in Kalkaji,
almost every day, I find one,
at least, but sometimes more,
parents are sitting and waiting
for my people and me to help.
Whose children are missing?
Whose children are
trafficked and sold?
They could not raise
those children.
And they have no hope,
because they cannot easily go
to the police.
The poor people in most of
the developing countries
don't have faith in
police, number one,
and no confidence in police.
Anyway.
So they keep on waiting.
So what we do, on
the basis of that,
we do thorough investigation
about the clues they give
and the knowledge they give.
Then we engage different
authorities-- police,
magistrate, the
legal department.
It is not so easy to coordinate
with different agencies,
but we had to.
And then be conducted
secret rescue operations.
In that operation, we
don't inform anyone,
even don't inform the
police the exact location.
We say that in that
area, these children
are confined in the
factory or a mine,
because it's always risky.
I lost two of my colleagues.
One was shot dead.
One was beaten to death.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Really?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Yeah.
And I had my left foot
broken, my leg broken.
My right shoulder is broken.
My backbone has a lot
of bruises and scars.
My head has scars.
So these people are very
strong people, mafia.
And if they come to know in
advance that we are going
to rescue children, then
they're prepared with arms
and become violent.
So we have to be very,
very, very careful too,
and very swift and secret to go
and do the rescue operations.
ERIC SCHMIDT: I'm, sorry,
so you literally go in?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
Very literally.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And
rescue the child.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Yeah,
thousands of times.
I have gone personally
I could not recall how many
times in the last 35 years.
But right from the beginning,
I go, and my colleague go.
And earlier, the police
was not so involved.
But later on, when the high
courts and the Supreme Court
of India became quite
proactive and started
directing the
authorities and police
to help and to go in these
rescue operations, only
then they started going.
So when we free
the children back,
there are a lot of legal
formalities in terms of handing
them over to the parents.
And then we bring those children
for rehabilitation centers.
My organization runs three
rehabilitation centers,
one for girls and two for boys.
And these children stay there.
And we try to restore their
childhood and sense of freedom.
But more importantly, we
build their self-esteem
so some of them can
become the leaders
and liberators for themselves.
Some of my children came to
address the UN General Assembly
side meetings.
Some of them have
addressed the Senate
and congressional
hearings in DC.
Some of them have addressed
the European Parliament.
So they have proven
that if they are
given the chance
and opportunities,
they are no less than
anyone in the world.
And they have shown
their leadership skills.
ERIC SCHMIDT: And what
happens to the people
who would enslave them?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: We have
strict laws on slavery
and human trafficking.
So sometimes the problem is that
the civil society organizations
have no idea, and
sometimes they don't
have capacity to use the
laws, because, first off all,
it is very risky.
If you will use against
those mafias, legally.
The softer approach is just to
take the help of authorities
and go and convince and take
the children out and send them
back home.
That is not enough.
But in my case, our
organization has
been working for the
enactment of laws,
for the enforcement of
laws, because if we rescue
these children under
the proper laws,
they would be entitled
for the rehabilitation
facilities and the governments.
And their employers
would be arrested.
Of course, in many cases,
employers run away.
We cannot find them when we
go for rescue operations.
But sometimes they are
caught, sooner or later.
And then they are arrested.
Of course, it's a very
cumbersome, very expensive
process to follow the
legal case in the court.
And they are rich
and powerful people.
They can go to higher court,
and then higher court.
So it's difficult, but at least
there is some deterrent in it.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Now, is every one
of these children illiterate,
essentially?
They've not been to school?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Some of
them have been to school.
Many of them have
never been to school.
Some of them are
registered in the schools,
but they don't
attend the school.
For instance, last year, we
have rescued 1,100 children
from Delhi itself, from
the capital of India,
with the help of
judiciary and police
in these rescue operations.
And 850 out of
them were enrolled
in their native villages
in their schools.
That means they were attending.
All the datas
which were prepared
was that these children
were in schools.
They were receiving a
stipend, and other facilities
of the government.
And the local government
furnishes that information
to Indian Parliament.
And the Indian government
furnishes that information
to UNESCO and other UN agencies.
So they were attending
those things on paper,
but they were enslaved,
and they were trafficked.
So many of these children
are removed from schools
with the protection of better
life and better living,
working conditions and so on.
And these traffickers
are quite smart people.
They move around.
They identify certain areas.
They engage the local
agents, subagents,
and they successfully
bring the children
and sell them out
to different places,
including for child marriages,
or brothels, or other places.
ERIC SCHMIDT: The
obvious question here
is, how much of this is sexual
exploitation of young men
and women, boys and girls?
And how much of it is
other forms of abuse?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
The sexual abuse
goes beyond the child labor or
child slavery or trafficking
issue, because sexual abuse
may occur inside the families
by some of the distant
relatives or in neighborhood,
in schools also sometimes.
It is not very uncommon
in many of the developing
countries, the sexual
abuse in different forms.
But when it comes to the
slavery and child labor,
commercial sexual exploitation
or child prostitution
is a very, very heinous crime.
What else could be
worse than that,
sexual slavery for children?
But when we compare with the
rest of the exploitative forms
of child labor and child
slavery, it's a small segment.
I'm talking about
168 million children
in full time jobs, where
a few million children are
the victims of child sexual
exploitation as child slaves.
But the newer forms are
evolving, like the pornography.
The children are being used
for the pornographic proposes,
knowingly or unknowingly.
They have no awareness
how they would be
used by the small smartphone.
People who were
carrying a smartphone,
they take the pictures,
they change the photo,
and then blackmail
the young girls.
And that has become quite common
using this modern technology.
So the awareness among
the youth and children
in schools and
colleges is very less,
that how to get rid of these
blackmailers and the people who
can manipulate their
pictures and so on.
Also, the tracking about such
people is equally important
and how to address this problem
with the service providers,
for instance, both in case
of the phone companies
as well as the websites
and other social media.
These things are new
challenges in the exploitation
of children in modern times.
ERIC SCHMIDT: It's
important to address it.
You're here in New York to visit
with United Nations, I believe.
Tell us, how do you
actually do this at scale?
I understand you go in
and you rescue a child,
very dangerous, and so forth.
But with 168 million children
in this kind of situation,
you need a scalable approach.
What's the best
way to start this?
You're talking to the UN
now about this, right?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Yeah.
I have been to UN several
times, not the first time.
I realized right
from the beginning
that rescuing 1 or 10 or
100 children is not enough.
When I started in
1981, after giving up
my career as an electrical
engineer, it was very hard.
Many of you must
have been genius.
In those days, we did not
have the software engineering
or the computer sciences, so
I did not go to that course.
So the most advanced was
electrical engineering.
And one has to secure
very, very good marks
to get admission in electric
engineering in those days,
40 years ago.
Anyway, so those days, we did
not have any law in India.
The United Nations
systems did not
have any international
convention
on rights of children.
It came into being
only in 1989 when
UN Convention on the
Rights of the Children
was adopted by the
international community.
So it was a hard time.
But we realized, I realized
that we have to fight for laws.
Without that, we cannot.
So we fought for it in 1985.
We succeeded in '86.
There was a new law in
India, the first time,
the Indian law against child
labor has been enacted.
We knew it.
Then be tried to link this
whole issue with education.
Right from the beginning,
I was advocating
that eradication of child labor
and education for children
are the two sides of same coin.
We have to ensure that the
government have good policies,
good programs, good investment
on education for children,
has preventive measures as well
as rehabilitative measures.
Then we realized that it
is not an Indian problem
because many of the
multinational companies
are operating in India.
All of the products
made in India
are sold in other
parts of the world.
The global political policies
and economic policies
are also affecting children in
different parts of the world.
So I had an idea to launch
a worldwide movement
against child labor
with a clear demand
that international
communities should
adopt a new international law
on worst forms of child labor.
In 1989, we organized
a worldwide march,
a global march
against child labor,
which went across 103 countries.
We have covered 80,000 kilometer
distance, which is double
the periphery of the earth.
And 71 heads of the nations--
presidents, prime ministers,
kings, and queens--
joined or supported it.
It had resulted in the
international legislation which
we are talking about now, this
worst forms of child labor law.
Similarly, we
realized, I realized
that I'm freeing 10 children,
but another 20 or 30 children
are entering into
slavery, trafficked,
to work in carpet
industry in India.
And I trusted in the
power of human compassion.
And everybody has some
element of humanity.
That was my belief.
90% of the carpets produced
in India, and 95%, those days,
produced in Pakistan
and Nepal, they
were sold to United
States and Germany
and other European countries.
So an idea cropped up
in my mind that why
should I not go to the consumers
and launch the campaign
to educate them, not to call for
boycott of South Asian carpets,
but with an alternate,
with a solution,
because I always
believe in solutions.
Problems, one can talk hours
and hours and days and months.
It's very easy to talk
about the problems,
but sometimes difficult.
But solution is must.
So I brought an idea that let
evolve a social monitoring
and labeling mechanism
through proper inspection,
transparent and professional
inspection mechanism,
running numbers of the carpet,
the code numbers and so
on, which can guarantee
that this particular rug is
free of child labor
in South Asia.
So that was the
first social labeling
introduced when the [INAUDIBLE]
corporate social responsibility
was not coined.
It was not invented.
Before CSR, we had
a successful story
to tell about the
carpet industry.
And the number of
child laborers,
according to various studies,
including the US Department
of Labor, those days in
mid '90s, was 1 million
in India, Pakistan, and Nepal.
And the latest figures
suggest that it
is no more than 200,000.
So there was a
significant decrease
in the number of child
laborers in carpet industry.
And as a result, we can
find job opportunities
to 800,000 adult people
in place of children,
because the quantity of
carpet did not fall down.
It is even more.
So many more adults could
find job in place of children.
So that was one thing.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So when you talk,
it sounds like this problem--
and you've done
your work in India--
but it must be a
pretty global problem.
So it's a problem in India.
It's a problem in Southern Asia.
That's a problem in Pakistan.
Where else is it a problem?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
It's a global problem.
As you mentioned, that there's
a problem in United States
as well.
In the West Coast, we have
children, Hispanic children
still working in agriculture,
farms, and other places,
and sweatshops also
in some places.
I started in India.
Then I realized that it
is a South Asian issue,
so I started working
in Pakistan, Nepal,
and Bangladesh.
And then, after the
global march in 1998,
we built a worldwide platform,
or worldwide coalition
of civil society organizations,
teachers unions, trade unions,
some of the businesses,
and brought them
in one platform, that is Global
March Against Child Labor.
We kept the name intact.
So we work in more than 100
countries, practically, now.
We have our regional
offices and coordinators
in South Africa, Central
Africa, East Africa,
similarly southern
part of America,
and Central America,
and North America,
similarly in Asia, South Asia,
and Southeast Asia, Europe.
So we work through 2,000
partners across 144 countries,
to be precise.
But some of them are
dormant and not so active.
But about 100
countries are active,
where we can raise
the collective voice.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So I
think what we should
do is we should go to the
questions from the audience.
And we also have
an internal system
which we called Dory,
which has already
submitted a few questions.
So I'll ask the first
question, and maybe we
can have people who have
comments or questions come
to the microphones.
First question on the Dory
is, "In India, we often
see children from poor
backgrounds working
in roadside shops,
factories, and mines.
They and their parents
often support this,
saying that if their
children don't work,
they won't have enough
money to eat food.
What is your answer
to this argument?"
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
First off all,
the children who are
working in the street,
restaurants, or whatever,
mines, they are not
responsible for poverty.
Somebody else is responsible.
This is the moral issue.
Who will take the
responsibility of poverty?
Why children should
take the responsibility
on their shoulders,
to carry it on?
And they will remain poor
for all of their life.
They will remain illiterate.
They will remain sick
while working as child.
This is moral.
But the economic argument
is that, globally, we
have 168 million children,
as I said, in full time jobs,
and 200 million
adults are jobless.
There are many studies
in several countries
which have proven that
there is a parallel
between adult unemployment
and child labor.
And also, most of these
children who are looking
are the very children
of those parents
who don't find jobs for
more than 100 days a year.
So that becomes
a vicious circle.
Children are preferred in jobs
because they are the cheapest
source of labor,
sometimes free labor,
if they are bonded labor.
Adults have to be
paid more money.
Adults would work only
8 hours or 10 hours.
Children are going to work
for 14 hours, 18 hours.
They will sleep and work in
those smaller restaurants,
street side restaurants,
but the adults won't.
So we have to break
this vicious circle,
and that understanding has
to be broadened and deepened.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Obviously educating
them will also help, right?
Because they will become
more educated adults
and have higher paying
jobs and all of that.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Absolutely.
We are living in the age
of knowledge economy now.
We cannot think of any
sort of social justice,
we cannot think of economy
growth of a society or getting
rid of personal poverty
without education,
and not only education.
Good quality education is must.
And access to the most
advanced knowledge is
must to be empowered and
to be the equal partners
in the globalization.
ERIC SCHMIDT: First question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
As consumers who maybe
don't know a whole lot
about this issue, or don't know
where to find out information,
what do you think that we
can do in terms of voting
with our dollars, or any other?
Can you just look at a
tag on a piece of clothing
or a sticker on an item
and know whether or not
it was made with child labor?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Well, this
is a very, very important
question.
I try to find answer at least
in rug industry with this label.
So if you go to buy a carpet--
which is not so often.
You don't go to a buy
a carpet every day.
But definitely the people
go to buy shoes and clothes
quite often, or the
sporting goods, or toys
for the children.
Unfortunately,
there is no credible
labeling system of
certification so far.
One of my future objectives
is to introduce not exactly
the same child labor free label,
but some sort of child friendly
labeling system, where the
companies who are committed
to certain things,
certain criterias,
including no child
labor, zero tolerance
to exploitation of children,
helping in education,
helping in health
care for children,
and also involving in
engaging supply chain,
building capacity, and
holding the supply chain
accountability,
then we can think
of introducing some
sort of certification
or some labeling where the
people can get something
better, not with 100%
guarantee that there's
no child labor involved.
But if the processes
are properly controlled,
then more chances that
there is no child labor.
Because when we go to do
the inspection at ground,
we need hundreds of thousands of
inspectors for garment industry
alone.
Garment industry is some
of the very common thing,
and which highly
depend on supply chain
and the local subcontractors.
So you need a parallel
inspection system
then the government
inspection system.
So we have to see that how
we can hold the government
inspectorate system more
accountable and more active,
rather than creating
a parallel system.
But those companies
who pledge to take
certain measures-- and we
can check those measures time
to time.
We can think of some
label, some sort of label
of being child friendly.
ERIC SCHMIDT:
Another question we
have from our remote
audience, "How can individuals
get involved in fighting
for children's rights?"
In other words, obviously
people care about this.
How do they make a difference?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
First of all, everybody
has to be friendly to his
own child, spend some time.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Start at home.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: We are
all busy with our own careers
and our own lives.
Start with home.
Start with oneself.
Be friendly to your
brothers and sisters.
If you are living
with them, it's fine,
otherwise you can use
the modern techniques.
Google is here.
So you are the people who can do
some Google Talk, or whatever.
So that is another possibility.
But to spend some time,
be friendly, respect them.
Listen to the children.
That could be the beginning.
And then the second thing
is that you are connected
with the [INAUDIBLE] knowledge.
And once you get to
know that in some place,
somewhere there is a systemic
violation of child rights,
and the children are
denied childhood,
you can simply
react to it by just
pushing some of your
fingers on your computer,
on your mobile phone.
Raise voice.
Break the silence.
By taking simple
measures, you can
be the part of bringing
about the change in the lives
of those children, and creating
more child friendly world
and respecting child rights.
Some of you, or many
of you can really
help in devising new
apps or new ways which
can be very helpful to
connect to the people
in terms of awareness
building, in terms
of engaging the young people.
Like him who was
asking what to do,
one can put some
[INAUDIBLE] on a Google app.
You can create some apps
to Android or whatever.
And I can't do it, actually.
I have my limitations,
because those days,
there was nothing like Google.
ERIC SCHMIDT: You are
an electrical engineer.
We expect you to be a program.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: But
I have my own limits.
And you guys are not only
sitting on enough knowledge
and creating [INAUDIBLE], but
you are the brightest brains,
really, in the world.
I am sitting here and
feeling so delighted
amidst you as the
brightest brains who
can bring about a lot
of changes in the world
through technology, and
through [INAUDIBLE] technology
in particular, and creating
new ways of engaging people,
giving them a feeling that
they're also partners of change
by just clicking some button.
They can stand for the
rights of children,
or something like that.
I don't know.
But that leave up
to you to think.
You have a lot of
innovation programs.
And I am so curious
to do something.
I highly depend on Google.
Let me tell you, Eric,
one thing, that the day
when the Nobel Peace Prize was
announced, I was on my computer
and googling one thing.
I was trying to find it
cheaper ticket for me
to visit to Germany.
So I thought that the
Google is the right answer
to find me a cheap
ticket to visit Germany.
And I found some good answers.
Then suddenly, some
journalist called me up.
He was an Indian journalist.
It was daytime.
And he said,
[NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE] Nobel
Prize.
[NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
is some sort of respect,
to pay some respect,
[NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE].
[NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
Nobel Prize.
He was so excited because I was
the first Indian born Indian
to receive the Nobel Prize.
And I was standing in the
league of Mother Teresa.
So he was so excited, so
he said half sentence.
So I thought that he's
asking for some response
or some reaction from me.
Somebody might have got
the Nobel Peace Prize,
and I thought that it might have
been declared in the morning.
So I thought the best way
to find is the Google.
I shifted myself from
one Google search
and opened the new window
for a new Google search.
I don't want to miss
my cheap ticket.
So I was looking, and
I started googling.
But I was a little
upset, frankly speaking,
because I was just
printing "Nobel Peace Prize
2015," and that time
it was appearing 2014.
And it was a matter
of a few seconds.
It will not even one
minute, actually.
He got the message, because
it was being announced.
It was still going on in Norway.
And this journalist was fast.
And I was a little
upset, that I always
try to find answers to
every single question, right
my health, to my acidity to
everything through Google.
And I could not find answer to
give it to this journalist who
got the Nobel Peace Prize.
And he was clever, with no time,
it appeared on your screen.
And also, some of my
friends came from downstairs
in my office and
hugging and kissing.
But it was there in few seconds.
ERIC SCHMIDT: This is why
we work at Google, guys.
This is it.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: And this
is why I am sitting here
and and want to work
more with Google.
And I'm so happy you were
able to simultaneously
be awarded the Nobel Peace
Prize and get a cheap ticket.
using Chrome.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You had mentioned
that child exploitation is
a global problem, obviously.
But I think there's this
notion that, well, it
happens in India, Pakistan,
maybe Nigeria, elsewhere.
How much of a problem is it
here in the United States,
and is it happening
right outside our door?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Well,
as mentioned before,
that many of the children who
are working in tomato or potato
farms, many of the children
who are working in oranges,
orange farms, in the West Coast,
some of them, or many of them
or Hispanic.
They are Haitian.
They are Mexican children.
And their passports
are controlled
by their contractors, and so on.
So they are working as child
laborers in this country.
But you cannot compare the
problem with the children
in South Sudan or children
in Pakistan or some parts
of India, children
in Afghanistan,
those who are the victims
of multiple problems.
They have to face systemic
violence, suicidal violence,
economic violence, and so many
other things, sexual violence.
So that is the problem.
But we know that in
sub-Saharan African countries,
this problem is more acute.
In South Asia, also a
serious problem, but a little
bit improvement.
In Central America,
we have some problems,
and different kind of problems.
Like, in Central
America, the problem
of commercial sexual
exploitation, child
prostitution, below
the age of 18,
girls are being used
for this, prostitution,
this is a serious problem.
In Southeast Asia, the
sexual exploitation
is another serious problem in
comparison to forced labor.
South Asia, forced labor,
or traditional labor,
where the children are born
and grew up in those families
where the parents
or grandparents have
borrowed money from the
grandparents of the landlords
in the agriculture sector,
or the stone minors.
That is a serious
problem, what we
call the
intergenerational slavery,
or intergenerational
bonded labor system.
So it varies from place to
place because of the traditions,
also because of the structures
of the society, then so on.
ERIC SCHMIDT: As I
mentioned, in the US,
there's an agricultural
carve out for this.
The steps stones are
no labor below 12,
14, 16, and 18 in the US.
But there are exemptions
in agriculture.
And there's a set of people
who are, for example, trying
to stop children working
on tobacco farms because
of the exposure to
carcinogens and so forth.
Obviously an issue
for adults as well.
It strikes me as
this is just a bug.
This needs to get fixed.
There's no scenario in
the US where we need
to allow the sort of thing.
It must be a holdover
from an ancient time.
Yes, ma'am.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
in, or at least
in the carpet industry, a, lot
of the buyers were foreign.
I imagine it's similar
for, especially,
garments and other things.
And I was wondering if the
countries that you know
are probably importing a
lot of these goods made
with illegal labor, if they've
taken any measures to bar
the import of goods with
kind of questionable origins?
And if so, have those
been successful or not?
There's probably
barriers to doing this
that I'm too naive to
think of right now.
And I was just kind of wondering
if there's been any success,
or what the situation is
from a policy perspective
from the countries that
are importing these goods.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Yeah.
At least in United States,
there is a specific law
to deal with the forced labor,
child labor, and bonded labor.
And the Department of Labor
produces a frequent report.
It's, I think, four yearly
or three yearly report which
is brought, and they
name the industries
in countries which
involve child labor
and try to negotiate
and pressurize
the countries of import,
as well as the industries.
But the blanket ban on any
industrial or any country
is not going to
solve the problem.
There are other ways
to deal with it,
as I've mentioned before, that
how to engage the suppliers
and supply chain, how to create
more protective environment
for children, how to invest
more on education for children
in those communities,
how to raise
the consciousness in
the communities itself,
because communities
and parents themselves
could be the very best
protector of those children.
They can be involved in it,
which is normally not done.
So awareness building and
consciousness raising,
engagement of the suppliers
and the subcontractors,
building their capacity,
sensitizing them is important.
Equally important to form the
multi-stakeholders initiative,
where the governments,
if possible,
but the businesses,
the civil society
organizations,
community organizations,
religious groups, the
teachers, the faith leaders
can come together and help
in finding the solution.
And of course, the
representatives
of the subcontractors
and suppliers
should also be brought into
account so that everybody
can work hand in hand.
So wherever we have
been able to find
some sort of
multi-stakeholders initiative,
we have seen some
positive results.
But that has to trickle
down at local level.
It should not remain an
international stakeholders
initiative.
It should go down at district
level, or state level, country
level.
And that process, this
is not just one go thing.
It's an ongoing
process for education,
and making the
people responsible
and eventually accountable.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: OK, thank you.
Yes, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: You spoke
briefly before
about deterrents
that are in place.
I was hoping you could
elaborate a little bit more
about the deterrents in
place, where you think
they might be falling short
on the social, economic, legal
levels, and looking
at it not just
from within Southeast
Asian countries, globally,
but the local levels, like
you were just mentioning.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Actually,
the laws are important.
But they are like the
tools, or the weapons.
Somebody should use those tools
at the right time, right place.
And that education
and that capacity
is needed when we talk of law.
Then the more important
is creating awareness
in the society and holding
the stakeholders more morally
accountable and
socially accountable.
The accountability is
something which is missing.
And accountability should be
evolved as a culture, not just
as an imposition,
legal imposition
that you have to show it.
Combination of both would
be the best ideal situation,
where the businesses and
other institutions, including
the government should be held
accountable if they're not
properly enforcing their laws.
But on the other
hand, everybody should
feel morally accountable.
I think the moral
accountability is
most effective and sustainable
than any other legal system.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Thank you.
Why don't we have our
last two questions
right here on the left.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
You mentioned that one of the
reasons that child labor is
favored, obviously, is
that it's much cheaper.
Children will work
for much longer days.
Whereas an adult might only
work for eight hours a day,
or something like that.
So there's a clear
economic incentive.
Do you think that
part of the problem
might be over-regulation
of adult labor?
That's clearly a very
tough position to take,
but at the same time,
there must be some way
that we can make the economic
incentive of choosing
child labor less favorable
for those companies.
So do you think
it's in deregulation
of other types of labor?
Or do you think
there's other ways
to close the gap of
making the incentive less?
KAILASH SATYARTHI:
Actually, using child labor
is illegal in most countries.
So when they go for
employing child labor,
they already do some
illegal activity.
But by way of
employing children,
they can save lot of
money as black money.
On paper, most of these
people spent, 30%, 40%,
50% of the production
cost as labor cost
that is shown on paper.
But practically, they
spend only 2%, 3%
by feeding them or keeping them.
Sometimes if they
give [INAUDIBLE],
it would go up to 5%
of the total production
cost, the labor component.
But the rest of the money
goes as black money.
And that black money propels
corruption and breaking
the laws.
So the people keep
on breaking the laws.
On the other hand,
the labor laws
are not really so different
in most of the countries.
In case of agriculture
labor, across the globe,
but mainly in
developing countries,
not properly implemented in
agriculture sector, no labor
law, properly.
Like, the minimum wage
and safety majors,
they're not enforced.
It is also a big,
big [INAUDIBLE]
that how the very basic
labor laws in relation
to minimum wage and
protection of workers
is properly enforced,
which is not yet done.
Only a few percent of people are
unionized, those who can fight.
And they are clever to fight for
much better conditions, better
wages, and so on.
But the rest of the
people who are not
unionized yet and living in
informal or unorganized sector,
they are not even getting the
benefits of the existing laws.
More important is to, first off
all, have good laws in relation
to child labor and
effective implementation.
And secondly,
investment on education
is preventative measures.
The answer lies in
education, basically.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ERIC SCHMIDT: Why don't
you have the last question.
AUDIENCE: I was
just wondering, you
mention about how you save all
these children from slavery,
and also measures
on how to get buyers
to stop buying the carpet
to prevent the income.
But where do these children go?
Because their families
are still in poverty.
They still have to work.
Is there any measures to make
sure they get educated instead?
Where does the money from?
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Yeah.
There are many social
protection programs
for children in many countries.
For instance, in India, we
have very strong measures
for rehabilitation of children
who are free from bonded labor.
That is the part
of legal system.
In Brazil, we have
very strong laws.
In Philippines, there are
some strong schemes for that.
There are many countries.
So those schemes have
to be properly enforced.
That is, again, a
challenge, also, because
of weak coordination
among agencies,
also because of
weak civil society,
or incapable civil society to
raise their voice strongly.
It goes on, no accountability.
In case of carpet
you raised, I did not
call for the total boycott
of South Asian carpets.
I called for the child
labor free carpets.
So the people should demand
child labor free carpet.
Calling for boycott of
anything is an easy thing.
But it did not work anywhere
in the world on any issue,
because people eventually
need those things.
If I called for boycott
of, say, apparels or shoes,
it's not going to work.
Maybe some people,
sentimentally or emotionally,
ideally, they can be engaged
for a few days, or a few months,
or a few years,
but eventually they
will go to buy the product.
So I was proposing that
consumers should demand a child
labor fee carpet.
And I have to find the answer.
Of course, I took advise
from many good minds
that how we can evolve a full
fledged monitoring and labeling
system so that consumers
can find the solution.
These children who
were withdrawn,
they created jobs
for adult people.
And the adult people were not
imported from other countries.
All those adult people
were found locally.
And they could find the jobs.
So the parents were able to get
better employment opportunities
in place of children.
And these children
went to school.
If they're not working
as child laborers
and there's no other job
opportunities for them
in that local area
of carpet production,
then they have gone to school.
And we did a regular followup.
We have devised certain
databases, certain tracking
systems.
And most of the
children whom we free,
right from the
identification and rescue
operations to legal actions to
rehabilitation and education
followup and so on,
that is also not enough.
And that's why in the future
I would love to learn and take
advice and cooperation
from Google
to help us in devising
more concrete tracking
systems, monitoring systems,
beside some kind of app
of engaging people, which
I was suggesting before.
Could be opportunities.
ERIC SCHMIDT: So as
you know, we have
had some meetings with you today
to talk about this precisely.
But what I would say is
that you were very kind
in your description
of us, but I think you
are the one who has courage.
I think you can see
what it takes to change
the world in the way you have.
I think we admire you.
We admire what you
did personally,
the risks you've taken,
and the many, many things
you will do for the next
decades in saving children.
Thank you very much
for being here.
KAILASH SATYARTHI: Thank you.
My pleasure and my honor.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]